another thing dr bite is not allowed to  do no showing bad movies to scp-682  hey that rhymed  scp-682 is famous for a lot of things  its indestructible nature its insatiable  appetite for violence and the  overflowing well of hate in its heart  unsatisfied with scp-682's ordinary  level of rage dr bright decided to take  it upon himself to give the lizard even  more things to be angry about an  organized and informal so bad it's good  film festival for the anomaly and  himself the resulting damage and loss of  life cost the foundation thousands of  dollars movies on the do not show to 682  list include the works of ua bowl the  work of neil breen the room troll 2  manos the hands of fate and let's face  it any other movie dr bright can think  of no  more  movies